it really doesn't have any money at this  point I don't even think he owns the  rights to I believe I could fly  [Music]  yes yes I think I'll be able to come up  with it's Saturday but hopefully now we  don't have for the out of town video for  the out of town video we don't have bail  bondsmen in Illinois in Illinois they  got rid of bail bondsmen back in the 60s  everyone can guess why they did that so  here a bond is set so the judge took I  get a million dollars and he knows what  he sets that then mr. Kelly has to post  10% of that amount so essentially it's a  hundred thousand dollar bond which is  exceedingly reasonable given these  allegations trying to get it together it  doesn't have it sitting in the bank  sitting in a shoe box